[Music]
welcome back to another ah awesome
episode of the careful boys and today we
have our amazing hot seat with the
wonderful jaspreet in the chair y'all
[Applause]
a worthy person could pull it out and
then
run the kingdom of j.k
i've been hoping for somebody to take
that out ever since
all right so we're in hottie so
obviously we like to put our uh you know
our special guests and i don't think
it's gonna work i'm gonna get it up
it will come out probably let's put our
you know uh friends of the hot seat so
we can ask some burning questions uh but
we also like to warm up into and start
super cold all right so the uh master of
chill mr freeze himself bart quan with
the coldest questions in the game start
it off brother and the uh
traditional spectrum
of a roy g biv rainbow
which one's your favorite color you know
it's funny you would say that because my
wife used to always ask me what's my
favorite color and i don't have a
favorite color i love all colors man i
think the only color minority mindset
y'all yeah very good very good answer
appreciation let's end it right there
keep going keep going i don't know
that's good i like all colors i think i
just don't like uh black too much i like
black cars
i like you like orange orange is a nice
color man is the new black what would
you wear orange with or what would you
use what was your favorite color with
orange orange and black look so nice
together like a tiger tigers are awesome
it's more orange
dominant though with with black stripes
i'm glad we're talking about the real
[ __ ] here
that's true
oh another caller satisfied with that
he goes all right that's it guys
you grew up in michigan right um
when did you come out here to california
on monday oh so you don't let me stop
here he still lives
i thought no because for i overheard
like you you were living in i lived in
san diego for two months and then i
moved back
um i was just there for two months uh
moved back and then uh came out to la
this week how many llc's have you
formally filed oh my god uh at least
ten wow maybe a probably a dozen
probably doesn't and how many do you
still like uh right now actually now
probably ten let's go
what industry haven't you gotten to yet
uh well i think the one you have to talk
like this so the one that um
i've had a lot of uh offers is the
marijuana industry but i have not gone
in it i don't go do anything that i
don't personally believe in i don't
believe in i don't get i don't do drugs
you don't think people get high off of
it do i think people get high for
marijuana yeah you don't believe that
people are getting high they're just
faking it
you don't believe it's profitable
i think it's very profitable i know
people make a lot of money in it but i
have not i've not done anything in that
industry i heard people get high off of
it yeah
yeah it's a big thing it's hearsay
really it's your say yeah it's cool like
i got no nothing against people to do it
it is what it is i just don't do it
myself you know what i mean
well then which industry are you
potentially curious about that you have
not broached yet which one's like
tempting i don't know um
i love the makeup business not for
myself but because my wife took me to uh
a makeup store right and i was looking
at these prices i was like wow like
these can't cost that much and i saw
this thing called beauty water
34.
and i looked at the ingredients it's
just water
but it makes me beautiful
and they put like a little bit of like
rose whatever in there i was like this
there's no way this costs more than like
60 cents to make sign up for 34
and i was like
jeffrey star is like a nine figure dude
dude yeah
nine figure like beef i think i don't
even think it was like during youtube or
was like before i don't know but
cosmetics it's always been a huge market
a huge industry yeah it's kind of sad at
the same time man because like it's cool
like there's a lot of money which is fun
to talk about but it's like
man it's like people i i hate the idea
of like oh i need to look a certain way
in order to be accepted you have to
market the insecurities that's that's
that's what i don't like about it you
know i totally agree with that until i
started uh learning especially like even
my girl like when she started watching
drag and stuff like that you know i
would always be like i don't get this
um and then i had to start flipping my
understanding of even things like makeup
not saying it doesn't prey on insecurity
or needing to like look a certain way
but there's also a community of people
that um
see the art you know yeah that i love
yeah that's the art on the face yeah
i think i think it honestly goes down to
everything i think everybody just needs
that basic level of confidence which we
don't teach in school the basic level of
mental health awareness so we can have
some sort of confidence so you can look
if you like makeup do it you know if you
enjoy it but don't it's just unfortunate
when you see because there are people
that like oh i wish i looked like this
so i could be happy so i could be loved
so i could be liked
but it's that basic level of confidence
right if i had
my own self-esteem my own confidence
then it doesn't matter what you do right
and that's that's one of the things i
just don't like is is that type of
advertising you are a very successful
and confident man so i have to ask you
this slightly warmer question yeah
what are you insecure about
what am i insecure about see i don't
think i've ever really been insecure
about a lot of things um let me think
about that what's another word for
nothing
he goes well i'm perfect
so i used to be insecure like i'll talk
about use because i i know if we go back
to like high school i used to be
insecure about like
money um which is why i when i used to
make money it was spent on dumb things
like as soon as that was the dumbest
thing you ever spent on so when i first
met a grand i bought like the studded
out crystal watch it's worth crap now
right and it was a grand which is like a
lot of money and i was in high school
and i bought this but then i had this
nice toyota i was driving and um
i still drive i still have it it's i as
soon as i got some money i put on some
tints then i put on some hid lights then
i put on uh
you have to the two 12-inch subwoofers i
upgraded the sound system i mean i put a
i changed the rims i mean i did
everything to the car and so i was
spending dumb money on that car right so
i used to spend a lot of money on things
like that
uh and i think it was because of
insecurity right it's like oh i want to
look cool i want to look i want to give
this certain persona but then as i
started to become more successful i was
like dude that was so dumb like i want
to do the complete opposite like even to
today
my car is worth 500
in michigan it's got no last week
last week one week or two weeks ago i
got a call from the hoa the homeowner
association from our neighborhood
they said um
and i was in california right and they
were like uh hey uh so we've had a
number of complaints about a junk car
sitting in your driveway it should be in
storage and i was like excuse me they're
like yeah there's no bumper on it
and people are complaining that it's and
i was like well actually that's my car
that's when i drive to work every day so
some people mind their own business you
know you're like a warren buffett no
honestly for me if i did it i'd do this
um
because i wanted to break away because i
wanted to know for a fact like i don't
need this to show it because like when
fans see me and i'm in this car they're
like wait what and for me i just want to
break through i will buy a nice car i
want it you know i'm just trying to
figure out the right time but for me
it's like
it's to break through these insecurities
because
still some things do get like you know
you're like oh you know i made this much
money i want to look a certain way i
want to have this nice thing but i i was
i tried to play these kind of games with
myself i'm like
let me see right and um
i tried to do that same one like social
media like i got off of my personal soul
like i did not go on social media for a
long time because it did give me anxiety
like i saw like i think these 22 year
olds driving these nice cars i was like
dang dude like he's killing the game and
i see all these things going on and i
was like
it's giving me a lot of anxiety and
just with things from all aspects of
life dang this guy's really jacked like
oh my god they look such a happy couple
like this you ignore life and you think
that life is this perfect highlight i
was like i'm just gonna get away and i
felt so free and now you know so so how
did you manage your business without
social media i have people to manage my
social media like i don't post on
instagram so like some like an assistant
is posting pictures on your instagram
and all that stuff yeah yeah now i
recently started going back on my
instagram like you messaged me i
responded um but if it was like six
months ago or a year i would have caught
him at a good time i wouldn't even know
i just didn't go on because i didn't i
did not want to touch my social media um
and i still i don't touch it as much as
i like
i i don't go on social media that often
so you said you have a wife i'm gonna
turn it up just a little bit more yeah
what's your favorite and most annoying
quality about
that's a good one paper and most
annoying i would say probably that she's
a perfectionist because i'm not that's
annoying huh it can be yeah because you
know i'm i'm the type of person where
just do it
right just bring it out she's very into
the details which i love about her
because she's so artistic she like she
sees the world very differently she's
super into like she if she came in here
she wanted she would remodel the whole
thing and make a look we need it too
can't you come
if it was me
i'm saying let's just do it yeah and so
if it was me you do need a remodel
just we do tear it down start fresh so
you know it can be like sometimes if we
want to do things like let's just say we
want to i don't know plan a dinner and
she wants to like do the decorations i'm
gonna do a dinner or some pizza we'll be
all right you know and she's like no we
gotta have this and that so on one hand
i love it and then sometimes like i'm
like okay let's get it done but
i love
you know
i love that creative part of her it's
just it's not something that i'm used to
and you need that balance in your life i
feel like because like even like in
business like i try to hire people that
are like think differently than me and
we put heads because like you know i'm
not a very systems a process oriented
person and so i brought somebody on
who's extremely systems are process
oriented and we don't always get along
because of that like we always have
different opinions but that's how we
come up with better
ideas to get things bigger because i'll
come up with a creative and he's going
to come up with a way to scale that idea
right so you need both how long have you
been uh married before we got married
one year ago this saturday
wow
let's hope you make it to saturday i
hope so man i hope so i don't think it
happens does that work
together we do she's a a business
partner with a minority mindset which is
now you talk about tax questions right
so now we we lived in san diego and
just like this is one of those things
where she learned so i lived in san
diego on a business trip because i was
meeting a lot of people doing a lot of
work here
with my business partner
working so this airbnb now can become a
tax write-off
our car is a tax write-off yeah we have
to explore san diego do all of this and
that but we're living in a beautiful
area
uh doing business but i get to do that
with my wife so it's you know it's like
a different way of understanding the
system yeah what was it like
when you told your parents that you no
longer wanted to be a doctor
and then after that what was it like
when you told them you no longer wanted
to do
law when i told them i didn't want to be
a doctor so i talked about those dj
friends of mine they were very close to
me and i think i spent a lot of time in
their basement sleeping there so i just
didn't go home a lot um it was tough it
was very hard um they kicked you out now
they kicked me out but they were every
time i came home was the same thing do
something good become a you know doctor
just just rethink it you can do all this
entrepreneurship stuff investing stuff
after you're a doctor don't worry about
going to the gym you can be healthy when
you're a doctor
and that's the things that i was you
know just it was a lot of like um trying
to convince you back into the world yeah
i knew i wanted something else but i
wasn't confident because i don't have
anything to show i'm like yeah i don't
want to do this but i don't know what
i'm going to do i don't know how i'm
going to do i don't know what i'm going
to become right so once you can kind of
have something to show is much easier
which is why i try to keep my mouth shut
as much as i can until i have something
to prove for it so you weren't the dumb
guy that kept arguing and saying i just
don't want to [ __ ] do it you're just
like okay okay and then you waited till
you had
something that was working and then you
said bam check this out because i wanted
to make my parents happy man you know
like you all know your parents come here
with nothing they work their butt off i
want to give back i want to take care of
them i want to make them happy like
that's what i wanted to do
um and so it's like
dang like i know how bad they want me to
have this degree i i try to actually
drop out of college um but they didn't
agree to that so i kind of started off
with something extreme like i'm gonna
drop out of college so then you anchored
it
i'm gonna not go to medical school so i
kind of won't go up that way and then i
was like i don't wanna this is a good
way to do it that's a negotiation tactic
right there
that's cool is there any businesses that
you started that are uh
focused on
your culture like bettering something
aspect of your specific culture like
making indian food less spicy
[Laughter]
i gotta improve that stuff i don't have
any so i try to
bring awareness to my culture
but it's tough because even like when i
thought of a business ideas i was like
what if i cater to people within my
culture whether the sikh community which
is the religion that i am punjabi
community but the issue is like i don't
want to just like only cater to my own
people because i was like i'm just
taking money from them i don't want to
do that so i for me
like the punjabi community the sikh
community are very close to me so i
always try to talk about it like look
yeah people are seeing somebody who
looks like me they hear somebody talking
to me you learn about the state in india
called punjab you learned about what a
sikh looks like um how do you say the
word sick because a lot of people say
seek i yeah i used to say seek i didn't
know it was sick yeah it's and it's sick
yeah so
it's the right way to say it is sick
so
indirectly i try to bring awareness to i
try to talk about some of the struggles
that the punjabi community has gone
through the sick community has gone
through so
not directly but indirectly i don't own
any indian restaurants you know
unfortunately he wants him
every indian person i know they either
have a connection to an indian
restaurant or a grocery store and i'm
like you don't oh man the hookup's not
there bro
the thing i like about your videos
though is that it doesn't matter what
race or this because it's just i mean
you represent as as a sikh because of
just appearance sick the sick on my man
but then
but but the video content like
it's it's just about you know
you know saving finance basic or
economics or whatever and then so you
don't really have to be a certain
culture to consume it yeah and the whole
idea behind minority minds has nothing
to do with the way you look at this
these skin colors the mindset of
thinking differently and what's funny is
that that incites a lot of racist and
nasty people to come and say oh you're
not a minority oh i'm not i cannot watch
this if i'm not a minority and it was
like
if you're thinking already that's me in
the comments i see a white guy like you
can't we don't belong here yeah yeah get
out of here stupid
that's so dumb what do you identify as
so and you know it's like you know if
you're gonna already come in and be
racist like it's probably not for you
and it's it's like a it's like a filter
you pick your own audience that way so
but you know it's it's one of those
things where if you want to learn
you can learn and if you don't like the
way i sound the way i look that's fine
it's a free country so you know youtube
is free go click the x button watch
somebody else it doesn't really matter
to me have you ever been uh bullied
growing up as a kid a lot man what was
like one of the worst times uh worse was
right after 9 11 because i was about 10
years old and you know under 10. i was
yeah i was 10. yeah and
obviously there was a lot of
misconception about what's going on
people wore turbans and this and then
and no one knew what a sick was and it
was a it was a tough time and i went to
a school with all white kids
and uh so i was bullied picked on a lot
like i was
i had my books thrown on the ground i
was punched i was spit on i had people
that ripped off my turban like it was a
pretty rough time like it was it was it
was tough
but i think you know it was one of those
things that either it made you tougher
or it really broke you and i was very
fortunate that it made me tougher
so and i think that helped me kind of
where do everything now where you know i
don't really care if i get criticized
because i was criticized my whole life
you know what i mean so
it is what it is
what's the uh meaning behind the turbine
like you're you're uh you're not
supposed to expose your head to like the
sky or yeah so there's a there's a
number of different meanings so the
turbine is actually a crown and so when
the sikh religion was created there was
a lot of
a lot of conflict uh between different
religions hindus muslims and india and
so the the uniform is almost like a
police uniform where if you needed help
you can go to a sick that is sick will
be there to help protect you they'll be
there to help take care of you
no matter what your religion is no
matter what your gender is there's no
differentiation of caste creed like your
income doesn't matter that if you need
help you can always uh find a sick and
it's a very easy to identify so it's
like a religious police force or
neighborhood watch group yeah i mean you
can kind of think about it that's not
like you win
yeah i heard people say that uh six are
like the warrior class is that true
that's pretty baller that's pretty tough
so six our blue lives matter too so sick
so six believe in duality that's the big
thing in it and that what that means is
uh there's two aspects you have to
master the spiritual aspect and the
soldier aspect and so you're supposed to
be spiritual meaning understand humility
understand god understand what it means
to be humble uh you know kind of have
that spiritual side but then the soldier
side is you're supposed to be tough
you're not supposed to be
weak as a sick you're not supposed to be
fat as a sick you're not supposed to be
eating crap all day not supposed to not
work you're supposed to be healthy that
way you can take care of others you're
supposed to know how to fight
um and how to defend yourself like
there's a
like there's a martial arts within the
sick religion
really yeah it's called gatka which is a
type of
a type of art fighting form that
you know many people are taught as from
young ages that way it's just basics of
defense to help other people so uh
you're supposed to know how to defend
yourself because not just for yourself
but to defend others the sick religion
at its core
is is
to help other people who can't help
themselves and so you want to be able to
help them whether it's financially and
even uh from
if there's a distress that you would be
there to help so you have like a
religious obligation almost if someone
is
like getting her beat or whatever to
kind of intervene and help you are
supposed to help those who can't help
themselves so let's say like uh you're
like financially well off and then let's
say we all like lost a bunch of money in
crypto and then we're like yo
we need help yeah let's make a video
let's ask your audience for some help if
um
we can turn off the camera it's more
like if you could just
hook us up with some bills yeah just
like write a giant check or something
you know yeah i'll give you my bitcoin
address
i lost 1.5 million on luna
what financial advice would be given
you should hear about my investments in
business dealings it's fun the majority
mindset yeah
there's a lot no that's called the i
should have a channel called a
degenerate mindset that was a good
lesson though you learned it's my second
time losing that much it's the second
time learning three times
[Music]
you